[موسيقى] هل
يمكن أن تكون النسخ الرقمية هي
الحدود التالية في الطب الحديث؟ لقد
ظهرت التوائم الرقمية مع الحاجة إلى
علاج شخصي، وهذا
مهم جدًا لمراعاة هذه
الفسيولوجيا الفردية ثم العثور على
الحل الأفضل لمريض أنا روزا
سانسيت و  أنا مدير الأبحاث في
شركة الكهرباء العصبية،
لذا فإن التوائم الرقمية في مجال الرعاية الصحية هي
تمثيل افتراضي للمريض، لذا
فهو يحاكي تشريح المريض
ليكون قادرًا على التنبؤ بكيفية تطور علم الأمراض
أو العثور على مؤشرات حيوية
قد تساعد في التوجيه
تشخيص الأمراض أيضًا للتنبؤ
بكيفية تأثير العلاج على كل مريض.
يعمل فريق سانشيز على تكراره.
ويمكن القول إن
دماغ الجسم معقد للغاية ونحن لا
نفهم حقًا كيف يعمل، لذا فإن هذا
هو التحدي الكبير لتطوير كائن
علمي عظيم.  القدرة على ترجمتها
إلى منتج حقيقي أو
منتج أو تقنية ملموسة ثم
القدرة أيضًا على الوصول إلى المرضى
كجزء من مشروع ممول من الاتحاد الأوروبي يسمى
التوأم العصبي. لا تصمم سانشيز
نماذج دماغية محوسبة فحسب، بل تستخدمها أيضًا
لإنشاء نماذج دماغية مصممة خصيصًا.  -
علاجات تحفيز الدماغ الغازية للحالات العصبية
مثل الصرع ومرض الزهايمر
لإنشاء بيانات دماغية رقمية مزدوجة يتم
جمعها في شكل تصوير
وتسجيلات تخطيط كهربية الدماغ التي تتم معالجة البيانات
من خلال التعلم الآلي الذي يخلق
نموذجًا رياضيًا يمكنه تكرار
الشبكة العصبية للمريض باستخدام
بمساعدة الحساب السحابي، يمكن بعد ذلك
استخدام التوأم للتنبؤ بالمسار الصحي للمريض
أو
العلاجات الشخصية. أتوقع هذه
التكنولوجيا الرقمية في مجال الرعاية الصحية
كجسم كامل من أجل
دمج جميع هذه الأنظمة
الموجودة وسيكون بمثابة معيار  طريقة
مراقبة صحة الجميع
[موسيقى]